[Music]
I'm not the type of photographer that's
gonna go out and find things to
photograph I'm gonna create things to
photograph Kathleen I started his body
work back in 2005 it's a series called
the city postulates a world post mankind
something has happened
that's a decimated the human population
so these are the city after man is gone
and it's just the way that buildings age
and crumble and nature takes back some
of the spaces and I thought just the
last thing that should be would be an
artist's studio and what better
reference do I have in my own studio
even though I may be only get behind my
camera three times a year and I spend
more time working with my hands I'm
definitely a photographer I'm more than
a sculptor I feel like I know how to
make the camera lie I only have to build
the diorama from one vantage point so
when you go into a 360 moving around
it's like going behind the scenes at
Broadway you know behind the curtains
are all the mechanisms to to make it run
same with the diorama if you've been to
our living room you'll notice that it
actually looks like the end of the world
looks like a disaster a disaster scene
and this model is kind of funny it's
actually cleaner than our actual living
room it's kind of sad to say we used to
have a couch and then like one little
table to work on get rid of the couch
yeah and got it a bigger table
yeah people either like all of the
clutter and find it inspiring or it
makes people really anxious and they
like really can't stay here very long
it's nice working within the apartment
because it ends up being a real blend so
do this and then I'll stop and maybe and
go make lunch and then
No do some other house things while they
paint's drying or something to come back
if I had to go somewhere I don't think
I'd find it as satisfying but then this
is also the dining table and you know
it's a double-edged sword for sure the
subway was in the living room in the
scene so we knew that we had to have it
in the final model too so I made a
replica of a replica of a subway
[Music]
initially I was just come in I do a
little bit here and there and you know
it was not either of our intention for
my role to sort of grow but I like this
but you were already pretty established
as you and you know we need that to keep
going but she gets so much grief from
her mother controlling the anger I think
for now it's kind of wound up where it
started it is Lori's name on the work
and I'm fine with that I want to make
things and you know having my name front
and center isn't necessarily why I want
to do it so far this has only had my
name on this work even though she's a
huge part of it but from I think from
here on out if if she wants it will
change the name from like Lori Nix to
Nixon Gerber
ya know Nixon / knocker burn eggs that's
a drug company if it's small and
detail-oriented Kathleen's gonna do it
because she has the patience and the
mindset for working small and delicate
and if it's a large requires any sort of
measuring and knife skills it's going to
be me although you do have good knife
skills but more for carving not for
cutting yeah
there's always like one thing that will
buy and we scale things up around it but
for this particular one we fabricated
just about everything in the scene a
flatbed scan all the books and my
bookshelves same with my CDs on the
internet I was able to find all of like
these CD covers so I typed in all the
all the things that I have in my
collection I printed them up and then I
glued them onto flex and then polished
for the edges to look like it's actual
CD case I'm a huge Cowboy Junkies fan
here's Kate Bush here's a Patty Griffin
for Kate Bush these Laury Laury made
they were a piece of like PVC tubing and
then as like a little washer to make it
look like a pinky very resourceful we
try to keep everything as as real as
possible I messed up on the on the flat
files because mine actually has five and
I only made four I don't know why cuz
they open and close anyone yeah they
open and close and very important for a
still photograph the things opening
class but there's the little details
that really make this scene come alive
like the fan in the back window the
power cords going everywhere little
items on the on the table
then Kathleen created this great chair
and the light and everything else I
really like your brushes I think they're
just great the cans and and the brushes
are amazing but uh I thought this would
be a nice way to in the series this is
just because we mrs. where we spend so
much time yeah this is where everything
is created is yeah this is everything
I'm too close to see the illusion I have
to like rely on friends to tell me
whether it works or not
especially with this one most people
look at when they look at our you get
their attention for I believe it's three
seconds maybe four if you're lucky
so I'd hopefully by making that that
juxtaposition between real not real
maybe they might look at the piece a
little bit longer if they even get into
this type of artwork it's not for
everybody
after I've lived with it for seven
months because that's usually how long
it takes us to build another photograph
then I take out what other objects might
be able to be repurposed in a scene and
then the rest gets broken down into
small pieces put into black trash bags
and taken to the curb some of the
objects will find their way into the
next body of work but have no problem
decommissioning the studio I love
throwing my scenes away because it means
I'm ready to start the next scene
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]